[MUSIC]
Hi, I'm joined by Jenny Tong, the
Developer Advocate on the Firebase team.
Welcome Jenny.
>> Hello.
>> So I've got this friend
who has developing an app and
considering Firebase.
Who's wondering if you have a little
time to answer some questions.
>> Of course.
>> So, I guess the most basic question
is, do you have some examples of
Firebase being used in the real world.
>> Yes, a few examples come to mind
of a few great uses of Firebase.
One is Go To Meeting which uses Firebase
for real time signaling between clients.
So you know when somebody's
taken the mike to speak.
Another example is Twitch TV,
which does video game streaming.
They use it for signaling all
their streams coming online.
My favorite is probably
Warby Parker's location in New York.
Warby Parker uses it to control
the pneumatic system that delivers your
glasses to you.
Right while you're waiting.
>> That's really cool.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So why did these
developers go with Firebase?
What was unique about Firebase
that made it the choice for them?
>> So, I think the thing that makes
Firebase unique because there's a lot of
options for building back ends for you
is just how easy it is to use Firebase.
People usually get pretty comfortable
with Firebase after a few hours and
have a production-ready app
within In a couple of days.
>> That's awesome.
So in your opinion what
is like the killer app or
the most differentiating
piece of Firebase?
>> So I think the applications that
work best with Firebase are ones that
are going to be generating a lot of
structured data from user interactions.
Like one of the classic cases of this
is chat which is one of the deceptively
hard things to build on your own.
So things that you can model,
think of as
a track communication between multiple
people work really well in Firebase.
>> So just expanding on that, in your
opinion what are the classic uses?
What are the best apps that
are suited for Firebase?
>> The best apps that are suited for
Firebase.
So any situation where you have
like low frequency information or
medium frequency information coming
from mobile apps or web applications,
that need to be synchronized back and
forth between multiple platforms.
[INAUDIBLE] Web and mobile.
All those combinations, or even
signaling internet of think systems and
you don't want to build up independent
infrastructure for each one of those.
>> All right well Jenny thanks a lot for
your time today.
>> You're welcome.